We're so honored to welcome a real-life hometown hero
right here to the desk.
She's a Drew-gooder and she's from Philly
who spent 30 years educating and cultivating the kids
who grow up here.
This year, in such a challenging time for students,
she launched Cooks with Books,
a virtual experience that pairs cooking with literacy.
This is so up our alley.
Take a look at this.
So we're making petite peach pies and I already made some,
they're already delicious.
I tried them, I'm going to show you them later.
But I'm also reading a super fun book today.
This is called, The Night I Followed the Dog.
Now please give a hometown welcome to a true Philly hero,
It's Marie Lambert. (audience clapping)
Yes!
Thank you so much.
I am so excited to be here.
This is just awesome.
I mean, you really like as a teacher and a nurturer,
what happened to you in life that, you know,
set you on a path to care about kids so much?
I was born into an educator-rich family.
Really?
So my father didn't have a lot of formal education,
but he believed that his children should all be educated.
I want to talk about what you're doing.
Your nonprofit, True Way Youth Empowerment Foundation,
it's been going for a decade now.
Yes.
That's incredible.
What is your mission?
So our mission is to empower, inspire,
and enlighten young people to tap into their greatness,
to think outside the box,
to be problem solvers and critical thinkers,
and to build strong character.
We do a series of games and activities to have them
really work through a problem without getting angry
or using foul language or violence.
They really have to use their minds
to really think about what they would do
and how they would solve a problem.
Now, the pandemic put a pause on the cause
and on your conference,
but you've got a very special plan for this year.
Will you tell us about it?
I am so excited because True Way is set to put on
the best youth virtual conference ever.
January, 2022, right?
The Think Outside the Box Conference.
The content of your character is a theme of it
and we are set to invite educators and professionals
in all areas of industry, business, the arts,
science, health and wellness,
and put on the best virtual conference ever.
Amazing. (audience clapping)
That is so cool.
We are just so inspired by your beautiful work
for Philly's young people.
So we reached out to our friends at Jada Toys
and they make the B-kind dolls, an eco-friendly line
that promotes messages of kindness
and inspires kids to be creative and compassionate.
And they want to recognize you with your kindness
with a $20,000 donation (audience cheering)
to True Way Youth Empowerment Foundation
to help and enable all the work that you do, Marie.
(audience cheering)
(laughs) This is so amazing.
(cheering drowns out speaker)
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, this is awesome.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I don't know what to say.
I mean, you're molding minds and hearts, Marie.
You're extraordinary.
So here you go.
Thank you so much.
Thank you Jada Toys and B-kind dolls.
And thank you, Marie Lambert, for being here.
Thank you so much for having me.
This was a blast!
(Ross laughing)
(audience cheering)
Congratulations.
Yeah, but this is exciting!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, I appreciate it.
Well, thank you, Marie.
And thank you, Rossi.
We got to come to Philly!
I know! (cheering)
(light, energetic music)